[Music]
I'm just trying to get some guidance on
how to put a 20year friendship to bed
they definitely did a thing my best
friend basically my brother he made a
pass at my fiance the kicker that I
can't get past he's like I just wanted
to know what it would feel
[Music]
like hey everybody what's going on this
is John with the Dr John delone show the
greatest mental health and emotional
health and marriage and parenting and
whatever else is going on in your life
podcast ever
recorded my friends tell me I speak
almost exclusively in hyperbole so that
may have been a bit of an exaggeration
but I'm glad that you are with us on the
show we talked to real people who are
going through challenges in their life
and my promise is I'll sit with you in
the mess even when nobody else will I'll
sit with you and we will figure out what
the best next move is if you want to be
on the show talk about your marriage
we'll talk about what's going on with
your in-laws we'll talk about your kids
whatever your your mental health your
emotional health whatever whatever you
got going on if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at 1844 693
3291 1844 693 3291 or go to john.com
askk and I do not know all the answers I
promise I don't know a lot of them and
if my friends and colleagues across the
country or the scientific literature
doesn't address it I'll say so out loud
I'll say I don't know
and then I think one thing that's
missing from the world is people not
just giving their opinion but saying
here's what I would do if it was my
sister here's what I would do if it was
my dad here's what I'd do if it was me
and letting you know here's the move I
would make in my house I don't have any
signs to back it up here's what I would
do and so it's a combination of all of
it I'm so grateful that you have chosen
to join us man and if you want to be on
the show give me a call and don't forget
my book my brand new one building a
non-anxious life I think it's the
antidote to the world that we live in
right now which is just Madness an
unintentional mad house run of muck um
building a non-anxious life lays out a
road map the six choices you can make on
a daily basis on a monthly basis on a
yearly basis to create a life worth
living to create a life that is not so
fried all of the time and it pulls
together tons of research tons of other
books tons of other authors that are way
more brilliant than I am and sets it
into a book I tried to make it as simple
as possible just a conversation between
me and you here's the next right move
and here's how to build something worth
a living right and so building a
non-anxious life go to John dooney.com
and pre-order it now it's 20 bucks and
I'm trying to bribe you so I'll send you
a bunch of other stuff like audiobook
and like a download talk I'll send you a
bunch of stuff go to john.com 20 bucks
check it out let's go out to California
and talk to Gerard what's up Jared how
we doing man pretty good Dr John
uh longtime listener first time caller
yes that's I always hope people will say
that and you did so that's awesome you
you made my day what's up man I got your
back man don't worry um yeah thanks for
taking my call so um basically I'm just
trying to get some some guidance and uh
maybe some next steps on how to put a
20year friendship to bed and let go oh
wait almost always that's a did a thing
what happened oh they definitely did a
thing a little bit of what is it man all
right so I guess I'll give you a little
bit of backstory um I have a a I mean
he's my best friend or was I guess I
should say basically my brother I mean
20 years is a long time to have a
friendship right hey call that up that
is a this sounds like the beginning to a
Dawson's Creek episode I'm not gonna lie
and I'm super excited about it two um
yeah that's a brother dude 20 years side
by side that's a brother right yeah
that's aely so anyway um I met my
fiance about five years ago we got
engaged last year uh our wedding's
actually coming up in 16 days at this
point very cool congratulations man
thank thank you um anyway so um my best
friend and my fiance they didn't always
see eye to eyee um you know it was uh I
think a little bit of you know vying for
my attention at some at some points you
know and uh so anyway they over the past
few years have really gotten close um
you know him and his wife we barbecue
together we hang out all the time you
know we're it's the crew right and uh
and so they finally gotten to a point my
fiance and and him where you know they
were they were tied everything was going
well and uh he
actually uh his him and his wife's
four-year wedding anniversary just
passed and he thought it would be cool
to kind of ropose to her because they
kind of eloped the first
time and uh he asked me to host it at my
house you know kind of a surprise
shindig repr proposal and I was like of
course brother like I got you I'll have
everybody over we'll keep a surprise
yada yada um so that all went fine it
was nice they stayed over
afterwards to you know barbecue hang out
we were having some celebratory drinks
and what have you and uh I ended up me
and his wife ended up um you know going
to bed it was late and I'm not together
right not together no I was gonna
clarify that all right yeah just I held
my breath there for a second yeah I was
hoping you were calling to tell me how
bad your friend was because you slept
with his wife okay good so that didn't
happen so you and his wife went to bed
separately I feel like I know where the
story's headed then what y he uh he made
a pass at my fiance what does that mean
he uh he tried to kiss her
okay and when they were and it it they
were you know out obviously by
themselves talking together and uh it's
funny because he it wasn't just like a
like a drunken oh I'm going to lean in
and make a pass like he physically
grabbed her face and pulled it toward
him to try to kiss
her and uh she pushed him away and
dodged it and was like you know what the
heck are you doing and uh he hopefully
she used stronger language than that she
definitely did I'm trying to keep it
right cool very cool you're a good guy
it helps the sound engineer not have to
make so many edits so good for you
exactly okay uh she pushed him off and
and dodged it so nothing happened but
then he went in and tried again kiss her
a second time and I mean she let him
have it my fiance is a a strong woman
it's part of the reason I'm with her she
she doesn't take any crap you know so
she kind of let him have it and
he uh he tried
to make her the reason for his choice in
that instance saying that you know
earlier in the night she had
complimented him and told him he looked
nice and he actually wrote us he was
supposed to be the best man my wedding
by the way so there's another there's
another wrench to throw in it but he
opted out of that role he he self-
selected out right definitely but he
wrote you a letter no he had written us
a song that he was gonna play at our
wedding was it a love song to your to
your
wife I mean it's hard to say at this
point looking back you know but anyway
it was it was obvious it was obviously
like an emotional song we were all
emotional and so you know he she like
had her hand on his shoulder like while
we were listening to the song and so he
used that
as uh his invitation I guess to uh to
make a a pass at her when I was asleep
God and and then then took it one step
further and was like you know uh you've
just been so nice to me lately and uh I
don't know what it is it's just your
eyes and here's the kicker that he said
that I I can't get past John is he's
like I just wanted to know what it would
feel
like and uh what an idiot well I mean I
had another word just idiot and so let
me let me I want to clarify something
just because I know in these
moments after 20 years like there's the
rage then there's the upset and then and
then if you're honest 100% honest
there's been some quiet in the back of
your mind did did she like lead on like
was she did she play any part of this
that's my that's my brother right and
let me be super clear I'm I'm thinking
right now and they're I'm sure they're
okay they don't listen to this show I I
assure you I'm thinking of two of my
best friends on the planet John and Todd
and their wives Jennifer and
Melissa
um and I'm thinking of my wife and those
two
guys I would trust my wife to go on
vacation with those two guys I would I
have sought out hey Melissa how do I
look in this shirt hurt and she would
say you look great man you like really
look handsome and not one time or
Jennifer hey can I come crash at y'all's
house while I'm in town for school
absolutely there's always a bed in my
home like right so it's some of the
kindest most hospitable and she I'll
walk in she be like oh my gosh you've
been working out and like yeah never
once is that an invitation to hook up
right 100% 100% because you know why
because those two men are my brother
others and that makes them my sisters
and my personal sister who I don't talk
a lot about she's she's mine like it's
real close to my chest um if she tells
me I look good at some like I look
handsome you look good except for my
wife that's like the next best good
feeling when my sister says that and not
one time do I think oh well I just want
to know what it's like to kiss you
that's just stupid man what an idiot
what an idiot what a violation man so it
was a complete violation so I'm because
yeah what's your question well I'm
struggling because you know obviously
like you said my first instinct was I'm
going to kill him right yeah uh and then
and then the the devastation and the
hurt set in yeah and just the complete
you know betrayal of it all and uh I've
just been really struggling with it I've
been anxious about it uh have you talked
to him I have I haven't talked to him
since uh I mean I confronted him once uh
when he decided to show up at my house
when when I finally found out uh and I
told him you know you just need to leave
like you're not welcome here like I I
can't talk to you right now you know um
and I just told him like I need some
space man like you know I will reach out
when uh when I'm ready to talk so so you
know uh I took about a week and then I
finally decided like okay I might be at
a point where I can like type something
out and send it to him you know and uh
because initially he sent me a text
message saying that he felt bad and
and you know he doesn't remember much
and then he said and then he said he
said if what's being said actually
happen and I'm more apologetic than I
can express and I'm like that's just a
cop out dude you know yeah so not only
is he as he
um did he make a pass that you're at
you're about to be wife uh twice
physically right and again like you you
mentioned it's not like there was like
this closeness and then like it just
kind of happened he grabbed her face
right he made a physical like he took
hold of possession of tried to take
possession of her body right that's
that's that's a that's layer that's a
layer deeper um then he doesn't have the
character to look in the eye and say
dude I screwed up in the deepest way
possible right he like uh if uh yeah I I
don't have any time for it man but get
get your question man get your question
I talked too long on these sometimes no
you're good you're good uh I just am
trying to figure out uh how number one
if I should even allow him to speak his
peace in this and number two like how do
I get closure from this man because like
obviously he's out of the wedding like
that's 100% but more than that like I am
at this point feel like I'm mourning a a
20-year friendship and I just I'm not
sure are if I need I'm not sure if I
need to give him a a chance to talk it
out or if I just need to find closure on
my own with this um
I'm I'm G to say something that's
probably not going be very popular on
the internet and I I don't care um I
think that's person
specific yeah I don't know the closure
is right for
everybody I know me I'm thinking back to
the friends I have that are 20 year
friends I personally I feel like I would
have to know like what were you
doing um that only can happen if
someone's willing to take ownership of
what they did right right which he's not
yeah and so at at that point I I got
nothing to say man because not only did
you did
you go after after my wife
but um you think I'm dumb and you're
calling me a
liar right like and you're calling my
wife a liar yeah so uh I mean at every
level there's violations of trust there
um I do like I got to tell you so for me
I hold those type of friendships so
sacred they're holy to me right they are
so um important that I would have to
hear somebody out that but but that is
not instructive wisdom for everybody
that's just me yeah I think in a lot of
cases
um that would be it would be
it it'd be it and here's here's I always
go back to the heaping burning coals
right um I don't think it would be
something where I'm going to puff up and
and act like a Instagram hero and try to
be all tough I don't think that's the
thing um I think the conversation to be
had is I need you to hear me say um you
violated my trust at the corest level
you tried to take possession of my
wife's body and I need you to hear hear
me say you've opted out a friendship
with me and my family so this is it I
wish you the best and um this is over
and I know it sounds dramatic and that
sounds like like a like a romantic
breakup but I think after 20 years
there's something to be heard that he
needs to hear the resolve for you not
the you because then you you pull
yourself down to his level right of this
like right you you turn into a high
school kid that can't control them
that's I'm not going to do that I'm not
going to stop to your level I'm gonna
let you know as an
adult you opted out of this and it
breaks my heart man you're my best
friend and bye right and and I think
there's something to that um but
also you and everybody listening that is
not for everybody there's some better
things just dude I'm not even going to
um I've I've gotten bit doing that like
going back to the well right getting
back like someone's ugly to me and I I
reach back out to them and it just digs
the hole deeper for me um I really try
to go the extra mile on some of those
things um and it's it's often not worth
it but for me I would feel the need to
say I'm putting a period into this I'm
ending this not you what you did doesn't
end things I am and um I wish you the
best and I'm gonna move on with my life
you know I'm see I mean that that'd be
the way I handled it I mean that's what
I've been leaning towards honestly
especially because like we mostly
communicate over social and that week
after it happened that I was finally
calm enough to write something out to
him I went on to our platform that we
normally talk on and I'm like oh we're
not friends so then I started digging
and he removed me from all social
media got a chance to talk to him so I
like that tells me what I need to know
bro get out of that world that's that's
like that's like he broke up with you in
Legend of Zelda it's not real right so I
I wouldn't go through like did you is he
following me is he did he like my post
get out of that planet dude you're gonna
drive yourself insane be a grown man um
and sit down and talk to him or uh talk
to him on the phone like I don't I don't
feel like talking to you I I don't want
to come see you or um or come whatever
but um
uh I I that's going to be that right so
I yeah I don't have some big magical
thing I wish I did um I could tell you
that I think the friendship's over I
don't know that you move past that but I
also think that um you get to decide
everybody listen you get to decide how
this the period end the sentence if the
period is I'm not ever having that
conversation again great great hold your
head up high don't be a child about it
it's over somebody violated you at at
your core and I'll also say this
um we are
often
um you know the old saying goes like he
stabbed me in the back we are often not
prepared when people we love and care
about stab Us in the face and it happens
they look you in the eye and they lie to
you they look you in the eye and deeply
betray you and what you said right
mourning and grieving that's what it is
it's a death of something cuz what we
had was Brotherhood what we had was I
will be there at 2: a.m. what it what we
had was you can always stay at my house
your wife can always stay at my house
and that's over
now and that hurts man it's not cool to
say it and it's like I don't want to
wait it's Dawson's creaky I get that it
hurts man it hurts and so there's going
to have to be a season of grieving that
and mourning that and then you Jared
you're gonna have to go find new 20 ofe
friends because you can't do life
without him and you can't be like oh
that guy hurt me that one time I'm out
no dude that's what that guy did and
I'll tell you I got some close close
close
buddies um very
close and I'm not worried for one second
about them making a pass on my wife I'm
just not and so um those friends are out
there there's more of those friends than
what your idiot buddy did and I'm
heartbroken for you man 20-year
friendships take 20 years to develop
that's hard it's a lot of investment in
time and love and I hate that you got
burned with it man man I hate
that but I can't make the call for you
but I I do want to know how you decided
to handle it holler back at me and let
me know U let me know how it goes and by
the way don't communicate electronically
be an adult No Electronic back and forth
that world's over call him on the phone
or go meet him for coffee we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to Omaha Nebraska what's up Jane how we
doing hi John I'm good how are you
partying what's up that's not true I
lied to you just now I'm not partying at
all what's up so my question kind of
revolves it's kind of a long thing but
more so about how to move on or forgive
after and I don't even know if this is
the right term like emotional infidelity
okay talk to me about it so my husband
and I have been together for over seven
years now just married for a little bit
less than
two and last December I found that he
was having like inappropriate
conversations with like not only
cooworker but an employee of
his yikes um so inappropriate like like
sexual sexualized okay all right yep yep
um it never even crossed my mind but you
know looking of course hindsight looking
back that November we traveled out of
town with the this woman and her
husband for a conference so we were all
down in Florida and they wanted to have
rooms close to each other so that we
could hang out and everything blah blah
blah
well I gotta just say that's the most
spurned woman thing blah blah blah right
so good like it was just it was odd like
okay whatever that's fine blah in
December all right my
husband um was taking our kids to go
play dodgeball for a work
event um I was supposed to go to a
concert that same Saturday night with a
group of girlfriends we both had plans
great it was fine well I ended up
getting sick Friday night
before um so I was out with the flu
while undergoing IVF treatments so that
I'm sure didn't help everything as well
um took our kids to play dodgeball hey
you need anything before I leave nope
just get out of here I don't feel well
don't want the kids around so that'll be
perfect um his plan was to go to
dodgeball and then everybody CU
everybody brought their kids to they
were all going to meet up at a
restaurant for dinner afterwards and
just hang out after and have a couple
drinks not a big deal so he kind of fell
off the face of the Earth that afternoon
SL
evening um come to find out my
mother-in-law actually came to pick up
my kids just a couple hours later and
took them to see Santa and my husband
decided to go to his buddy's
girlfriend's house with him and his
buddy who was a newly divorced gentleman
and this other
Girl by
themselves and this had been set up like
two weeks in
advance what happened there they had a
yeah so they had a whole group
conversation for a week before and he
just gave me a bunch of false details
there was never what happened at that
house oh well I don't know he turned his
location off on his phone he say
happened at that
house while I like to think that nothing
physically happened no what did he say
what did he say oh that they just had
some beers and ate pizza and played
cards that's the dumbest thing I ever
heard like and with his buddy they do do
that but it's always guys and then we go
out to our cabin and we do that like his
friend like I've known this guy for
years as well so I just thought well
that's just weird why would you turn
your location off you were not honest
with me about going to This Woman's
house and then I found out of course
through questioning I just had a great
gut instinct unfortunately
like nope they didn't go to dinner they
went to This Woman's home he actually
left their home with this other girl to
drive her back to work because she was
actually supposed to be at work training
a new
person so they drove around and were
hanging out by themselves for an
undetermined period of time all right
let's so let's stop playing Matlock
bring me to the bring me to the present
like this clearly this happened right
yes and um there's a H I've just just
lost it um it's too early in the morning
um there's a legal term which basically
says there's a moment when um the judge
turns to the jury and basically because
of the deception that appears to be
happening in the room you all get to
make up whatever you
want maybe it's pleading the fifth I my
lawyer friends are going to be
embarrassed that I don't know this SC
top my head but there basically because
you created this environment jury yall
get to imagine whatever worst case
scenario you want to and that is fact
because this person won't speak up and
let us know what actually happened and
so I'm giving you that opportunity
because your husband chose to deceive
and lie you and lie in so many ways in
such a premeditated way you get to
imagine whatever you want happen to that
house yeah okay so bring me um we are
months away from December so bring me to
up to speed how can I help um so I mean
obvious viously I mean he continued to
like lie the entire conversation that we
had about that and he kept trying to
cover it up and then he lied more and Y
and bring me it out he's a liar and he
cheats on you continued to communicate
with this woman okay he's opting out of
relationship with you yeah he's out he
has opted
out so his justification for the
continued conversation gred there's none
whatever you're about to tell me there's
none
here's why because his wife looked at
him and Saidi think you cheated on me
with this woman and he Saidi promise I
didn't she's just my friend and you as
his wife said this makes me
uncomfortable this makes me sick to my
stomach I don't trust this and any
self-respecting romantic partner in that
moment goes then this ends because there
is no other relationship more important
than
this so whatever justification there is
I don't care even despite how um not
cool cool it is is probably the most
benign way I could say that besides
possibly illegal possibly whatever if
it's somebody that works for you then
for sure I'm gonna have somebody like
this person's boss this person's leader
talk to them not me that's that
communication that's the problem well so
he's her
boss
um so this what is it last
Monday was when I found that she had
texted him and what's even better is
that her best friend texted him an
inappropriate picture of these two
girls and he you know deleted it from
his phone and he ended up responding
like I'm married this is inappropriate
I'm blocking your number don't ever try
and contact me again good for him
but like the fact that that happened
like obviously like he has he does not
do well with confrontation where I'm all
for it if it the situation calls for it
except you're not deal you're dealing
with this why not no so this I did so I
actually told him that if you don't go
to HR and address it I will and I
promise that you will both lose your
jobs I do not care okay this is not okay
I'm at that point where I'm already like
one foot out the door okay so what's
your
question so well okay so this girl got
removed from her position you keep going
back to the story tell me ask me your
question ask me your question I'm just
trying to decide
like do I just call it quits or do I
continue to try and work and do therapy
and counseling with him as now you know
he says it's not going to
continue what's not going to
continue like conversations with
anybody outside of our marriage didn't
he say that last
time that's the thing however all of the
conversations that I had seen were work
related because given his position he
has to be available like 24/7
um like he's a director of an emergency
room so he has to be available at all
times and as the fact that she was his
employee there were times that she had
to be in communication with him yeah I
get that I mean I I mean I get it in
theory right I've been on call 247 365 I
get that life and you have to you just
gota gotta answer I get that and you
know he kept the conversations very
short and sweet he actually did have a
documented conversation with her between
this last last incident and the first
incident where it was documented with
another member of the staff and HR that
your communication with me is not
appropriate that's not what you should
be doing you need to keep it
professional Okay the reason that you
should be acting this way so there was a
previously
documented thing so that that that that
to me like um is a step in the right
direction but right I you keep focusing
on him and you're and so doing you're
avoiding Jane you're avoiding you okay
the only way I've seen this and by the
way I have seen this
repaired completely like and not only
repaired but something else more
magnificent has been built in its place
okay not to say that people should run
out and cheat on their spouse just so
they can build something new no but um
I've seen it happen two things have to
be present for that to happen or three
the first one is everybody's got to be
honest about what happened everybody
and you still have doubts to the
original Integrity of his
story and just as a guy Roman walking
down the road who's been married for a
long long time that story sounds sketch
here's why
um if you premeditate something for
weeks to set something up and you go to
the trouble to deceive your wife have
somebody else come pick up your kids I
mean the whole that the whole
thing you don't do that for a couple of
beers and cards mhm you know I mean you
go play you go play you go drink beers
and and and play cards at worst you tell
your wife hey I'm going over to my
buddy's house and you don't tell them
that she's goingon to be there you don't
go through this whole thing something
else was going on okay so that's number
one I don't buy the story you got to
have complete honesty across the board
and that might be you saying okay this
is the
moment this is the
moment I'm interested in in staying in
this thing because I I I have a sense in
your heart you are but you feel like you
should leave and that you're kind of
stuck between a rock and a hard place
and that rock and a hard place is Jane
left and Jane right so I think there's
something to be said for I'm interested
in it but we can go no further until you
say
everything the second one is you have to
be honest and very very
clear about what trust re Building looks
like because you can't have him read
your
mind yeah you have to say if there is
any work conversation between you and
this woman I get to see it and by the
way we review your text once a week or
I'm going to put this app on your phone
if that's what you
need if you turn your tracker off then I
file for divorce like whatever you think
you need for a
season to begin to rebuild Trust
but most people don't have the courage
to say what they actually need and then
they just get mad when the other person
doesn't meets them doesn't read their
mind right the third thing is if you are
in you and and again he's not on the
phone I'd be having a whole different
conversation if he was on the phone but
with you if you choose to
stay you have chosen to
stay and this cannot be something that
you keep in your back pocket every day
for the rest of your
marriage and that's what I think I'm
definitely struggling with I can tell
because even even the ability just to
say hey what's going on in your heart I
gotta I want I gotta tell the story
again I gotta tell the story again I
gotta tell the story again and my Pro I
guarantee you you have looped that story
in your mind for months right yeah and
have you imagined things that happened
in your mind for months oh yeah yeah y
yes and then you get sick and then you
get mad at him and so now you've cre
he's granted he set this world up but he
is now um on the receiving end of your
imagination and as I told you earlier he
he created that right by by just giving
you a stupid story he didn't even try
hard to lie to you right uh by giving
you a stupid story fine I get to make it
whatever I want
them and so those three things have to
be true for this thing to work and what
does that look like in real time um the
first one is you have to decide that
every time that thought Pops in your
mind about him walking in that
apartment that you stop that right
there you don't go that extra Road where
she walks up to him and he reaches up
and undoes the top but you can't you
can't do that you have to choose to opt
out of that imaginary scenario because
you don't know and even if you do know
you have to choose to not continue to
revisit that scenario because y'all are
building something new
now that's your
work
but also I'll say it again you can't do
that work on a on a foundation of
dishonesty and he's got to come
clean
yeah and if he comes clean and says I'm
looking you in the eyes I'm holding both
your hands I'm sitting here with our
counselor I did not have physical
relationship with her I sounded like
Bill Clinton just then um yeah I sound I
was just tell Kelly just I sound like
Bill Clinton just then
um you have to decide whether I can
believe him or
not and I've heard men look me in the
eye and say dude I didn't do anything
and she'd don't believe me I've heard
that and I've also heard women be like
no I trust him and I'm like what why are
you trust so I can't I can't give that
to you but you're gonna have to decide
that that's gonna be have to be a call
that you make I recommend having a
neutral third party there whether that's
a counselor whether that's a minister
y'all trust whether that's somebody
that is going to help navigate the
conversation
um but it's got to start from a place of
honesty it's got to start from a place
of you telling the truth like here's
what I need and it's going to be you on
your
side saying I'm G to stop going back
to I'm going to try to build something
new and he's going to have to live into
the things that you you requested of him
he's going to have to be a person of
integrity and stop um either stucking
sexually explicitly with his his someone
who works for him which is completely
inappropriate or sleeping with somebody
that's that works for him it's
completely inappropriate whatever he's
have to stop all that nonsense and it
sounds like what you're saying is he's
making some steps in that right
direction I also know it is so easy that
when somebody has a crush on you that
you lean into that feels good feels
awesome
and it just becomes a slippery slope
right she becomes a slippery slap I get
it but yall going to have to choose to
build something new
regardless let me know how that
conversation goes Jane I wish I could
just wave my magic wand and say this is
what you should do but there's a lot of
complexity here um and I still don't
think the truth is
out and he wants to call me I'd love to
talk to him that would make for um some
clarity for me and probably be offer
some clarity for the audience too we'll
be right back
hey good folks it's that time again
school is back in session it's time to
get back to the routines we threw out
the window in May got to get up early
drop your kids off pick your kids up and
no more ice cream for dinner your
schedules are about to go Bonkers with
games concerts helping with homework and
a hundred other things but I've got an
important reminder for you please please
make sure you prioritize your sleep for
your kids for your marriage
for your work for you getting 7 to9
hours of deep rejuvenating sleep is one
of the best things you can do for your
physical mental and emotional health and
for me good sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why I love
dreamcloud mattresses and right now
dreamcloud is making it easy with an
incredible deal just for our listeners
40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 in savings go to
dreamcloud sleep.com and enter promo
code John delone today that's dreamcloud
sleep.com and into your promo code John
deloney all right we're back let's go
out to Chicago and talk to Megan what's
up
Megan yes hi how are you Dr D I'm good
what's up dude how are
you I'm doing pretty good too thanks for
asking my husband and I are just huge
fans of you so we just wanted to like
give a little shout out and say thank
you for all you do because you've really
helped improve our lives and also I
think he's a little jealous that I get
to talk to you today um are you guys
coming to the uh live event
Chicago we are so we're very excited
about that all right I want you to hang
on the line and uh I'm gonna get your
info from Jenna and I'm Gonna Get You
backstage and you can come meet
everybody and get photos and and all
that kind of stuff is that
cool that is more than Beyond cool oh my
gosh my my husband's going to be so
excited okay but you got to tell your
husband like hey like I I know some
folks and so I hooked us up okay cool oh
I will I'll I'll say it with my friends
over at ramsy Network and even better if
you don't tell him at all and you ask
him to wear the literally the dumbest
shirt he has in his closet and then
surprise him they'll be captured in
photo photo photo forever right okay so
all right onto the call so what's
up um so I guess I'll ask my question
and then give a little bit of context um
so now that I'm newly a mom uh how do I
stop my chronic people pleasing and set
up boundaries for my daughter with
family well you do seven summer salts
and some jumping jacks and it goes away
I'm just kid so what give me a scenario
you called for a reason what
happened um so I have like kind of two
scenarios one that's recently happened
and then one we're trying to figure out
how to newly approach since the one
didn't go as how we were hoping um our
daughter was born extremely premature at
26 weeks and for the safety of her we
set some rules uh when she finally came
out of the NICU um but now we've
recently been kind of like guilt tripped
into trying to break those boundaries
okay hold on I'm G interrupt you as we
go is that cool yeah oh sure I'm gonna
teach you how to do this for yourself as
a people pleaser okay
so one of the most important things is
to not let the ball get pushed off the
top of the mountain because the stone
because it just starts rolling and it
collects things you remember those old
cartoons where the uh the snowball gets
pushed off the top of the mountain and
by the time it gets to the bottom it's
just huge yes that's what our thoughts
do okay so I'm gonna interrupt you and
this is what you need to do as you're
heading into the rest of of motherhood
okay okay number
one this child is your baby you and your
husband's baby you you made some rules
as a couple about the health and safety
of your baby probably in consultation
with a
doctor nobody else gets a
vote
okay yes cool all right so when you are
walking on the street and you're like I
know but they're starting to guilt drip
me I'm gonna interrupt myself and go
hold on I'm the mom I'm the Mom nobody
gets a vote except for my husband that's
it all right on to the next Okay so
guilt tripping
you yeah I mean they've always just
guilt tripped Us in general by way
in-laws um um all four sets of families
sweet yeah uh well because my parents
are divorced and then his parents are
currently working through their divorce
oh fantastic we we have yeah so we have
four sets of families um and she's the
first grandbaby oh jeez
awesome
yeah um so I'm trying to break this like
being a people pleaser and learn how to
set boundaries because I want to lead by
example just knowing like I don't want
my daughter to grow up the same and
struggle with things and situations I
have because I was kind of raised this
way um kind of
100% a th% yeah okay here let me let me
let me interrupt so here's at the of
people
pleasing what I think what I know and
what I feel matter less than what
everybody else thinks feels and
knows and so the reversal of that
process is to begin with what kind of
Life do I want to live what kind of home
do me and my husband want to co-create
together right and you you you build
that out that way and often this sounds
counterintuitive and it's very non-
instagramy right start with
feelings what what do you want your home
to feel like when youall walk into
it I want my house and I'll tell you me
and my wife did this exercise I wanted
my house to feel warm when I walked into
it and interestingly that meant I had to
clean up my
crap and when my house feels chaotic and
a little bit
cold it's often because I've got piles
of just stuff everywhere I'm a piler
right I wanted there to be laughter and
joy in my house more so than frustration
and bickering and
chaos last night we put all the phones
away and we played trivia Pursuit and we
have the kid one for when my daughter
gets there and my son's with the adult
one we were talking trash we were
laughing dancing it was a just turned
into a mess and it ended with crying and
Tears like they usually do but the 80%
we got out it was awesome right so but
we chose I want our house to feel like
this and then we reverse engineered that
with what do we have to do to make it
that make it feel like that right and
and conversely what do we want our
holidays to feel like what do we want
the first three months of our baby's
life to feel like and what do we need
what has to be true for that to to um
happen and it might be we don't visit
we're not visiting family for the first
90 days it's our first baby we're going
to get our head screwed up on straight
this baby was really dicey out of the
gate we're going to make sure
everybody's on top of things and then
we'll reach back out and that's you
ending people pleasing by saying I
matter the way I feel what I know to be
true what my doctor suggests what I
think that stuff
matters and that's how you work your way
out of
it and you're like that's cute okay but
how do I make them not hate me
right well uh so she's been home for
about two months so we did kind of go
through similarly that but funny enough
my question was about the days and how
we approach that because uh we want to
kind of change family traditions and
start our own here which would like
include having Christmas morning alone
say that out loud probably in an
email okay okay say that in an
email me and let's pretend your
husband's name was Dan me and Dan are
creating our new family traditions for
our CORE family unit and part of that
will be we don't travel on New Year's
Day part of that will be we don't travel
on Christmas Eve we wake up and have
Christmas as a family unit on Christmas
morning and then you all decide what
comes after that if he has to go back to
work the next day that means we have
from noon until 7:00 p.m. at night
before baby go goes
down and I want to tell you this this is
hard in divorce families and this is
unpopular what I'm about to say and I
don't
care they chose to get
divorced they
chose they decided as adults to either
be able to or not be able to be in the
same room
together they made that choice as adults
they're not babies they're not
kids and so if they have chosen to get
divorced and they chosen to not be able
to I'm not be in the same room with him
or it'd be too weird great we're making
one
stop so we'll see y'all this year and
we'll see them next year Tada that is
not y'all withholding that is them
making adult
choices you see the
difference yes yeah you Megan are not
responsible for other adult choices
you're responsible for you and your
family unit and you and your husband
working
together right yeah and I know that's
hard but listen sending an email is good
because a that keeps the pressure people
from talking you out of what you've
already decided that stops the okay but
all right I'll call you back let me let
me think on it um but Dad but your dad
has to do this thing and your stepmom
needs to go do this with her kids and so
we need you to be here at that's not not
going to work this year and so if you
send out a map
via email this is the way this is going
to
be and let me be honest with you 100%
you're going to put up these boundaries
as soon as you had told everybody you
were pregnant they created a picture in
their mind of what this baby was going
to do for their
life very accurate so any boundary you
put up is something they're going to
have to grieve because it's changing the
picture that they created
but your baby is not a puzzle piece in
their puzzle their this baby is not a
pass ofier for their life this baby is
not a uh a cigarette or a drink to make
them feel better about the world they've
created this is a human being and it's
yours and so I say that to say expect
them to be upset with you expect them to
be like well I just can't believe that I
that's fair that's
fair and I'm going tell you on the back
end of that years years
later my in-laws my parents are so
respectful when we say hey this year has
been bananas this year we're going to
have way more time this year we we can
spend two days this year we can spend
one day or we're not traveling at all
that's the email we sent out last year
hey we're not we're not going to be on
the road this year um John's traveling
like like crazy meeting with businesses
and um we're just not going to travel
we're going to spend a a time together
as a family and we're also not hosting
this year we're just going to take a
year off I know that I know that was
hard for my parents I know that and they
were so respectful because we built a
culture of they trust the son that they
raised my wife's parents trust the the
the daughter that they raised that
they're going to do what's best for
their family
unit
see what I'm
saying yes yes yeah uh the mama baram me
really wants to do this I guess it just
hurts when I get called neurotic for
doing so listen listen they're going to
call you way worse before it's
over and can I be honest with you you
probably are a little neurotic and
that's
okay you know right probably you are a
little bit yeah okay so it's fair it's
fair what I think is really important in
these moments um honestly is a couple of
girlfriends of yours that you have
24hour 365 text
availability um I remember watching my
wife she was smart enough to get that on
the front end and it was a it was a
Lifeline because she was able to text um
a group of three women I think it was
maybe four 247 365 hey is this rash
normal is this weird what happens if
there's fever like I feel like I hate my
husband is this all normal and they had
she had friends that would respond
instantly and um there is uh I'll push
back on culture a little bit here too
there is part of of a family Legacy you
have to make the trip sometimes right
you got to go see family it's it's long
it's annoying um being a part of a
family tree is not mean it's always just
the greatest thing ever there is long
road trips for a one- day trip there is
expensive flight sometimes that's part
of it
and so I don't want you to create
boundaries so much that you isolate
yourself from
everybody um but you get to decide when
those long trips are going to be and for
what purposes and having a group of
women in your life that you can text and
be like am I crazy am I neurotic and
they'll go yeah you're insane go to the
birthday what's the matter with you um
and they don't have any they don't have
any skin in the game other than they
love you and they'll tell you the
truth is that fair that yeah it it it
keeps you from feeling like you are
fighting in-laws by
yourself mhm and having to decide why
all four of these adults couples um are
ganging up on you
right right yeah um here's the here's
the exercise I want you to do I want you
to get with your husband and I want yall
to start with how do we want the first
holiday with our new baby to
feel we want to feel adventurous do we
want to feel still and quiet and calm do
we want to feel gentle do we want to
feel like a party you get to the side
everybody's
different and then you get to decide
from there okay that means we we
probably shouldn't travel this year if
we want to be calm and chill we should
not travel we want to have Adventures we
want our first our first uh Christmas
with our little one we want to be like
fun and like we're cool parents still
great get a twoe road trip take off work
go get them right y'all to decide that
but I want youall to begin to map it out
and as you enter into September October
send the email out early to All
Families this is what this is going to
be and by the way if they're like we
don't like to be included on emails with
your your your mother's ex-husband sorry
I'm sending one email guys I'm not gonna
I'm not going to cut the crust off your
bread you can be an adult um but I'm
going to send this out to everybody and
just say hey look
um here's it we going to do for
Christmas this year here's when we're
going to be available or not available
and um we're so honored that you'reall
going to walk alongside us as we create
this new family and I think just taking
some ownership there let them say what
they're going to say and by the way if
they say a bunch of ugly mean stuff then
um they may opt out completely you get
to decide that you get to decide that
stay on the line um Jenna's gonna um
she's going to get your info for the
backstage stuff and um she's going to
send you a copy of my brand new book
building a non- anxious life I want you
and your husband to work through this
book together in the exercise as You
Follow The Path I think it would help
your home your entire home to say okay
who are we attached to that's running
our life for us who are we trying to
please what companies are telling us
what we're doing with our time and our
money and whatever it's going to help
you reclaim ownership it's it's a book
about empowerment and hope and I want to
give that to you all as a gift as your
uh as a as a baby gift um for you all to
create a home that's going to be
different than the one you grew up in
and a marriage is going to be different
than the one y'all both watched fall
apart and a kid that's not going to be a
people pleaser but a kid that's going to
know their own inherent value and worth
you're awesome we'll be right
back hey what's up Dr John deloney here
check it out my new book building a
nonanxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're going to be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
you're going to learn the choices you
can make day by day to create a more
peaceful joyful less chronically
stressed non-anxious life plus when you
pre-order my book I want to give you
something to help you today that's why
you'll instantly get my newest talk
smoke fire and freedom that I gave to to
several thousand folks a few months ago
where I break down the misunderstandings
and myths we believe about anxiety how
to reclaim your freedom and how to build
a non-anxious life so pre-order building
a non-anxious life today for just 20
bucks at John dooney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
Kelly just brought in um Rick SP
Springfield lyrics Jesse's Girl what
what are we doing here so when you were
on the first call with Jared about his
best friend hitting on his
fiance immediately in my mind instead of
Jesse's Girl I started singing Jared's
girl there we are I wish that I had
Jared's girl yep
huh all you that write in your comments
and say that I'm the one that has the
problems I want you to see what we're
working with here no I want y'all to see
what I'm working with that explains a
lot all right so we're going to insert
insert it Jared is a friend yeah I know
he's been a good friend of mine Jared
bro we're just
we're just laughing with you cuz that's
all we can do
right but lately something's changed it
ain't hard to Define Jared's got himself
a girl and I want to make
her mind this is just going to get dark
quick and she's watching him with those
uh I think I'm probably just going to
stop here this is the part where Delona
usually gets himself in a lot of trouble
cuz he thinks things are funny that
other people don't I love you guys stay
in
school be nice to each other or be kind
at least tell the truth be good see you
soon
bye-bye